with the rise of cyber attacks and data
breaches it's never been more important
to make sure that your organization is
protected against hackers
this series is about cyber security
architecture and we're going to talk
about two different areas fundamentals
where we're going to go through and
discover what some of the principles of
cyber security are that need to be
applied to everything that you do and
then the second part is on various cyber
security domains here we're going to
explore how to identify vulnerabilities
Implement best practices and defend
against a wide range of cyber threats
through an all-encompassing cyber
security architecture by the way I'm an
adjunct professor at NC State University
and there I teach a 400 level course on
Enterprise security architecture this
video series is based upon that course
the bad news is you won't get college
credit for watching these videos the
good news is no homework and no exams so
yay all right let's get started with
cyber security fundamentals
all right we want to start with five
security principles that you absolutely
should do and one that you never should
do so stay tuned to the end to find out
what that one is the first one we're
going to talk about is this notion of
defense and depth defense in depth is
trying to create an obstacle course a
difficulty for the bad guy so if we take
a look uh at an old security model the
castle well the castle was designed with
thick tall walls to keep the good guys
on the inside the bad guys on the
outside and it worked pretty well until
you realize the good guys sometimes
needed to come out and therefore we
needed to put a door on this thing well
the door then became a vulnerability and
so we we would try to reinforce it and
then maybe put a moat around the whole
thing because that made it even harder
and then the door with a drawbridge so
now we've got a moat which is harder to
cross we've got the thick tall walls and
maybe we even added an angry dog here on
this side something to give assist
system of security mechanisms because
defense in depth is all about not
relying on any single security mechanism
to keep the system safe now let's move
and transition into a modern security
example here we've got a user who is on
a workstation who's going to go across a
network to get to a web server which is
going to hit an app server which is
ultimately going to hit a database now
what would we do for defense in depth in
this example well one thing I might do
here is I might add multi-factor
authentication that is a system where I
make sure that this user is who they are
because I'm asking them for something
they have something they are something
they know some combination of those
kinds of things now how about over here
I might do if it's a mobile device or an
endpoint of some sort mobile device
management important device management
software that makes sure that the
security policy that we have set for the
organization is in fact followed on this
device it's got the right patches it's
got a password that's of sufficient
length and things like that we might
also add something like an EDR which is
sort of a Next Generation antivirus an
endpoint detection and response
capability to make sure that this
platform is secure then from a network
standpoint well I'm going to add in
firewalls to keep the web server secure
from the outside and also allows only
traffic that I choose to allow to get
back to these more sensitive zones and
then for the app server and the web
server I might do some testing some
vulnerability testing on those so that I
make sure that those systems are not
vulnerable to attack and then ultimately
I'm going to take the data back here and
I'm going to encrypt it lock it up put
access controls around it so you can see
what I've done here is there's no single
security mechanism that is protecting
this thing if any one of these fails the
rest of the system still works and
that's the idea that we're after here so
if you think about it this way we've got
a no single point of failure we're
trying to avoid single points of failure
and we want a system that ultimately if
it fails it fails safe that's what we're
trying to get and that's what the old
model and the new model of Securities
were designed to do
the second principle we're going to
review is the principle of least
privilege principle of least privilege
basically says I'm only going to give
access rights to people that need that
that are authorized and needed in order
to do their job and can justify it and
for only as long as they need that
access right for instance in this
example I've got three users this guy is
not really have a business need so we
don't give it to him the other guys get
the access right they can prove their
need and the other thing is even for
these guys the clock is ticking I'm not
going to give them this access right in
perpetuity forever we're going to
constantly be going back and making sure
that they still need that capability if
they don't we're going to remove it from
them as well
now another notion in the principle of
least privilege is hardening a system
let's say we've got a web server like
this and the web server out of the box
default configuration is that it runs
HTTP of course because we need that in
order to do web traffic but let's say it
also turns on an FTP server and an SSH
service so that I can log in remotely
well there's some things that I might
look at and say okay I do I really need
this FTP server if it turns out I'm not
going to use it I should remove that
service entirely in the SSH if I'm not
planning to use it remove it entirely
because every single one of these
Services is potentially expanding our
attack surface and making us more
vulnerable another example of hardening
is to remove all of the unnecessary IDs
that are on the system and change the
names of the IDS that we do keep from
their defaults so for instance if the
administrator ID on this system out of
the box is as it's configured is admin
let's change that let's make it
something
more specific and I'll name it after me
or give it some other name change all
the default passwords we don't want this
thing in just a vanilla configuration
because the bad guys will know what that
is and they'll know how to break in
another example is this idea of
privilege creep let me illustrate that
let's say there's two people that work
for the company and each one of these
are access rights that they have so this
guy is able to do these things he can do
the same things because they perform
essentially the same role
now this guy gets a promotion and a new
job and new responsibilities well he
goes to the administrator and says okay
now I'm doing my new job I need you to
add to my capabilities and these are the
things I need administrator gives him
those and then also says you know what
just in case I think you're going to
probably need this let me give you that
as well that way you won't have to come
back and ask again or come back and
bother me is what he really means okay
the problem with this is just in case is
just the opposite of principle of least
privilege in fact what we should be
doing is running an annual
recertification campaign
at least annual some organizations do it
more frequently than that and in
research I go back and look at all of my
users and all of their access rights and
make sure they still have a Justified
need so this person's still doing the
same job still needs all of that great
they keep it this guy though no longer
needs this capability because his new
job doesn't require it so we're taking
it away and this thing that he got just
in case we're taking that away too so
what we're trying to do with the
principle of least privilege is to give
only the access rights you need for as
long as you need them hardened systems
we're going to eliminate privilege creep
and we're going to eliminate the just in
case principle
our third principle to keep in mind with
cyber security is this notion of
separation of Duties that is we won't
have any single point of control in fact
what we're trying to do is force
collusion by two Bad actors or more than
two Bad actors in order to compromise
the system but no single person can
create the compromise so an example in
the physical world would be if I had two
people here and I've got a door with two
locks on it and this guy has a key to
this lock and this guy has a key to this
lock and
what it is is now if he uses his key to
open the door he still can't open the
door he can't open the door alone but
the two of them together cooperating can
in fact open the door so there's no
single point of control therefore we
have a separation of duties now taking a
look at another example here let's say
in an I.T case here's a requester and
this user wants access to this database
so he's going to ask for that he's going
to send in his request but then there's
an approver who's going to have to take
action on it and say yes or no based
upon whether we think they should have
it or not then if they get the approval
then they're given the action that they
want you know whatever it is the the
funds transfer the access to the
database the the package delivered
whatever it happens to be but notice the
point here this person the requester is
not the same as the approver they cannot
be the same person because if it was if
I could request and approve my own
request then there is no separation of
Duties so again what we're trying to do
with this is create a necessary case for
collusion which is hard to do because
it's hard for lots of people to work
together and keep a good secret and what
we're trying to avoid is this single
point of control
the fourth security principle that we're
going to talk about is secure by Design
in other words it shouldn't be an
afterthought that we put Security in
think of it this way if you were
designing a building in an earthquake
zone you want to make this building able
to stand the pressure so you don't go
build the building and then after it's
all done go back and say now let's make
it earthquake proof no you want to do
that from start to finish all the way
from design through completion so let's
take a look at an I.T example so when we
have a project you know we will tend to
start off with requirement stage we'll
go then into design we'll code the thing
then we'll install whatever it is that
we've written then we'll test it out and
then we'll promote it to production and
then in theory we should feed that loop
back and continue the continuous
development process that way well what
we don't want to do is what too many
people do in these cases and they wait
until really about this phase to do
security once it's already out there
security can't just be a bolt-on that
you do at the end in fact it needs to be
something that we're doing throughout
pervasively we look at the security
aspects of the requirements we build
security into the design we're thinking
about secure coding principles all along
the the path when we install we do it on
a secure system we're testing and and
guarding that test data and then the
production obviously we keep testing so
security is something we do throughout
but it doesn't begin here it begins in
these phases that's what we're really
looking for here now if you think about
another example let's say
whose job is security well it's really
everyone here we have a designer an
administrator and a user so really all
of them are responsible for security in
one way or another but who does the job
begin with well it begins with this guy
right here we need to make sure that he
is designing Security in in other words
what we're trying to do is make security
start to finish and we want secure by
Design means it's secure out of the box
that's the way we'd like it to be now
sometimes we're going to have to do some
configuration changes to make it more
secure but this is the goal that we're
trying to shoot for secure by Design
secure out of the box
our fifth security principle is the kiss
principle it stands for keep it simple
stupid in other words we don't want to
make it harder than necessary because
that will make it easier for the bad
guys and harder for the good guys
to give you an example we're trying to
create some level of complexity so that
it's not easy for the bad guy to get in
but a lot of times the security
department will create this complex Maze
of things that the good guys essentially
have to go through and what happens in
that case is I start in here okay I log
in now I have to Traverse and eventually
I'm like oh I'm at a dead end okay maybe
let's try this again you know what it's
too much trouble to do what the security
department has asked me to do
I'm just going to subvert this and I'm
going to end up doing it that way which
is of course not what we're after so the
lesson here is if we make it harder to
do the right thing than it is to do the
the wrong thing people are going to do
the wrong thing so we need to be able to
make the system secure but also as
simple as possible so keep it simple
stupid here's an example of how we do
this in security departments for real
we'll come up with password rules so
we'll say this is your password
and it equals this and it's this because
we created a complex set of rules that
say you have to start with an uppercase
then you follow with a lower case then
you need a special character then you
need to throw in some numbers and then
you have to have some mixture of upper
and lower case and special characters
and all this kind of stuff and it has to
be really long and by the way we need
lots of these you're going to have a
different one on every system and I'm
going to make you change it on a
frequent basis that's this that's what
the user sees is a complex Maze and
they're going to find a way to do this
and what they're going to do is find one
password and write it down and set all
their systems equal to the same thing
which is again not what we were after so
what we want to do is understand
complexity is the enemy of security so
we want to make the system just complex
enough to keep the bad guys out but not
so complex that it's hard for the good
guys to do what they need to do
for instance you might have noticed well
what about defense in depth which I
talked about up here there might be some
conflict in that because there we're
trying to set a system of security
mechanisms in place to put an obstacle
course for the bad guy we want that
obstacle course to be for the bad guy
not for the good guy
all right now we've gone over five
security principles that you should
always observe and now the big reveal
the security principle you should never
observe and that is security by
obscurity that is relying on some sort
of secret knowledge in order to make the
system safe it turns out that secrecy
and security are not the same thing
in fact what we want is a system that is
open and observable and this guy called
kirchhoff came up with what's now known
as kirchhoff's principle which basically
describes that he was specifically
talking about a crypto system and he
said basically a crypto system should be
secure if you know every single thing
about it except for the key in other
words the key is the only secret in the
whole system now why would this be an
issue well it turns out a lot of people
and you should whenever you hear this
you should run a not walk but run away
when you hear somebody say I've invented
a crypto system that's proprietary and
it will take your clear text you feed it
into my algorithm along with a key and
then it will produce from Clear text to
ciphertext okay great the problem is
this is a black box I can't see how it's
working and if the individual says it's
unbreakable I've been hacking at it for
weeks months you years all that means is
the inventor couldn't find a way to
break it but that's not the same thing
as the whole world given access would in
fact break this and in fact given time
they will even if it is a black box
history has shown that to be the case so
what we want is not Black Box security
we want class box security so in this
case what we have is the clear text goes
into a crypto algorithm which we
understand it's been published in fact
if you look at the good crypto
algorithms that we rely on today it's
things like AES the advanced encryption
standard and RSA
these are algorithms that everyone that
wants to know how they work can look it
up and see and the secrecy therefore the
security doesn't come from some secret
knowledge of how this thing works it's
able to produce ciphertext from Clear
text without having to keep this part
secret the only secret is the key and
that's what we want we do the same kind
of things when we talk about secure
operating systems or secure applications
or things like that as long as the
security is based on secrecy it's not
really something that we can rely on
thanks for watching before you leave
don't forget to hit subscribe that way
you won't miss the next installment of
the cyber security architecture series